- Alright, so first of
all, welcome to all of you.
I'm sorry that we're a little delayed,
but we're really fortunate
that the director was able to,
with the commissioner,
participate in an event with our state,
with our senator, our mayor,
our governor at Fairhaven
with the groundbreaking
of the new building
at the Fairhaven Community Health Center.
I'm Howie Foreman from the
Department of Radiology.
And on behalf of the
Department of Radiology
and the School of Public Health,
I really wanna welcome all of you
and appreciate your patience.
We have a great event ahead of you.
This is a collaboration between
the Department of Radiology
and the Boroff-Foreman Lecture,
as well as the Yale
School of Public Health,
the Dean's Lecture Series.
This could not have happened
without the sincere and complete support
of both of those entities.
And at this time there's a
million people I'd like to thank,
but for the most part I want
to thank our speakers today
and I'll do so now.
I'm gonna hand it over in a
minute to our commissioner
to introduce our speakers.
I'm also grateful to
our dean, Megan Ranney.
I'm grateful to Mandy Cohen,
who is our Yale alum who
committed to this event
seven months ago.
And we thought it would be
a few little simple small events
and then things intervened.
I'm also convinced that
she and our other guests
have helped us avoid
a government shutdown,
because otherwise we
couldn't have done this.
Also thankful the Solomon
Center at the Yale Law School
under Abby Gluck and
the Yale Medical Council
with leadership from Wilton Sun
have been really instrumental
in making us be able
to pull this event off.
Cannot thank all the CDC staff,
but I do wanna particularly
thank Ursula Shell
for her work in
collaborating on this event.
So Dr. Manisha Juthani,
who will soon take the microphone
and introduce our speakers,
is a Yale faculty member on leave.
Having taken on the
enormous responsibility
of Commissioner of the Connecticut
Department of Public Health,
a position that she has held
over these last two years,
including helping us steer
through the end of the pandemic.
Dr. Juthani is a world renowned
infectious disease clinician
and scholar and has
been a forceful advocate
for the ideal of healthcare
as a human right.
Her work is infused with a commitment
to health equity and she helps us tackle
some of the greatest public
health challenges of our lives.
She's a graduate of Penn, Cornell
and trained partly at Yale
before joining our faculty.
I will turn it over to her
and I wanna just thank
everybody in advance.
Thank you very much for doing this.
- Thank you very much
for that introduction, Dr. Foreman.
And it's a great honor to be back at Yale
as always and to be here
with these esteemed speakers here today.
So I want to introduce our two speakers.
Our first is Dr. Mandy Cohen,
who is the director of
the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention
and the administrator of
the Agency for Toxic Substances
and Disease Registry.
She's one of the nation's
top health leaders
with experience leading large
and complex organizations
and a proven track record
protecting Americans' health and safety.
Dr. Cohen received her
bachelor's degree from Cornell,
her doctor of medicine from right here,
Yale School of Medicine.
Great to welcome her back.
I'm sure that's when
she'd befriended Howie.
And you know, her
master's in Public Health
from the Harvard School of Public Health.
She trained in internal medicine
at Massachusetts General Hospital.
Dr. Cohen led the North
Carolina Department
of Health and Human Services
where she was lauded for
her outstanding leadership
during the covid crisis,
focusing on equity, data accountability
and transparent communication.
She also transforms the North
Carolina Medicaid program
through the state's Medicaid expansion
and her focus on whole person health
with the launch of the country's first
statewide coordination
platform, NCCARE360.
Prior to joining CDC, Dr. Cohen served
as the Executive Vice
President at Aledade,
the CEO of Aledade Care Solutions.
And Dr. Cohen was involved in many aspects
of the Affordable Care
Act policy development
and implementation during her time serving
as Chief Operating
Officer and Chief of Staff
of the Centers for Medicare
and Medicaid Services,
as well as Acting Director of the Center
for Consumer Information
and Insurance Oversight.
It's with this outstanding background
that we are so fortunate
to have her now leading the CDC.
And now to Dr. Megan Ranney,
who is the dean of the Yale
School of Public Health
and the CEA Winslow
Professor of Public Health.
She's an emergency physician, researcher
and national advocate
for innovative approaches
to public health.
Dr. Ranney earned her
bachelor's degree from Harvard,
her medical doctorate from Columbia
and her master's degree in
public health from Brown.
She completed her residency
in emergency medicine
and fellowship in injury
prevention research
at Brown University.
And she was previously
a Peace Corps volunteer.
Prior to arriving at Yale, Dr. Ranney
served as deputy dean
at the Brown University
School of Public Health,
the Warren Alpert Endowed
Professor of Emergency Medicine
at Alpert Medical School
of Brown University
and was the founding director
of the Brown Lifespan
Center for Digital Health.
Dr. Ranney's research
focuses on developing testing
and disseminating digital
health interventions
to prevent violence and related
behavioral health problems,
as well as on the COVID
related risk reduction.
She's held multiple
national leadership roles,
including co-founding and
senior strategic advisor
for the American Foundation
for Firearm injury reduction in Medicine
at the Aspen Institute.
A nonprofit committed to ending
the gun violence epidemic
through a non-partisan
public health approach.
And being co-founder of Get Us PPE,
a startup nonprofit that
donated and delivered PPE
to those who needed it most.
She's an elected member of the
National Academy of Medicine.
It's really an honor to
have them both here today.
I'd like to say as all of us,
all three of us being mother of two women,
as women being mothers
of two children each.
(Manisha laughing)
Got tongue tied on my words.
But you know, it's really remarkable
to see these women in leadership
with this outstanding background
and we are so excited to hear
their conversation today.
- Thank you, thank you Dr. Juthani.
So thank you for joining us today.
I do wanna apologize again for the wait.
Thank you for your patience.
Great things come to those who wait.
And thank you Dr. Cohen
for joining us all the way from Atlanta.
In my conversations with
faculty, staff, and students,
I know how much so many of you
have been looking forward to this day.
I know there are many others
who are unable to attend in person,
but are looking forward to
watching the recording on Zoom.
And we're grateful for your
coming back to New Haven,
a place that you once called home.
So, as you all know,
I launched the Leaders
in Public Health series
as one of the first event series
of my deanship here at Yale
School of Public Health.
I, like so many of you in the audience,
believe deeply in the power
of extraordinary public health leaders.
And I'm committed to
bringing these leaders,
thinkers, and doers here to Yale
to share with us a little
bit about their career path,
lessons learned and providing inspiration
for those, particularly students,
who are going to go out and
be change makers themselves.
As we pioneer together,
a new era of the Yale School
of Public Health's independence
will continue to have
speakers and collaborators
that are doing work centered
around inclusion and community,
innovation and entrepreneurship,
communication and of course
data-driven leadership.
Today's event with Mandy
is only the second of what
I hope will be a long series
of bringing our community together
across the school of public
health, the school of Medicine,
and the rest of campus.
Before we get started, I
do have a little surprise.
Those who came to my last deans lecture
will have a heads up.
I want you to look under your seat.
Eight lucky people have a small memento
to remember this event.
There are some empty
seats, so take a look.
- That is so Oprah of you, I love it.
- Who got them?
- Got them.
Show us your...
- Show us show us the little swag.
- There you go.
- Got some mugs in the back down here.
Excellent.
So congratulations to you.
A memory of Dr. Cohen's visit.
So without further ado,
I'm gonna move us into the discussion.
Dr. Cohen, it is such a privilege
and an honor to have you here.
We're honored you,
we got to share the stage sometimes
over the course of the covid 19 pandemic.
I've long been an admirer
and an acquaintance
and I'm just really
thrilled to have you here
joining us today.
- Thank you.
- So I'm gonna start at the beginning,
not going back to the beginning
of your time here at Yale,
but rather the beginning of your time
as North Carolina Secretary of DHHS.
I call that out because as Dr.
Juthani can no doubt attest,
there are some unique things
that you learn in public health.
As the head of a state health agency.
Wondered if you'd mind sharing
with our esteemed group of
students, faculty and staff,
how your understanding of public health
and the role of that
intersection of government,
private sector and nonprofits
changed over your tenure as secretary.
- Sure.
Well, first before I,
oh, can you all hear me?
Before I dive in,
I do wanna say thanks for having me back.
It's wonderful to be back in New Haven
and it's been a wonderful day
of being at the Fairhaven Clinic
and seeing them do a groundbreaking,
if they're expanding what they're doing.
And I think that my education here at Yale
was really pivotal for me.
It allowed me as a student to think big.
And it was the first
time where folks said,
it's okay to think about
how do we want the world
to be different and how are you
going to fit into that space.
As a first year medical student,
Yale supported us to go
over to South Africa,
a bunch of students
and actually get hands-on
experience in global health
working on the HIV crisis at the time.
And it was just the start of a journey
thinking about where do
I fit in to all of that.
And I've been incredibly
lucky to have taken,
I'm grateful to have taken some risks
actually early in my career to say,
I want to think about leading
in the public sector space.
And then sometimes you also get lucky.
I was also in the right
place at the right time
with the Affordable
Care Act getting passed.
Frankly, I was in the right
place when CMS entered
a crisis when healthcare.gov
didn't turn on.
You might not, you all might be too young
to remember in 2013, that crisis.
But all of these were
incredibly formative.
So that when I came to
North Carolina in 2017
and I lived there for five years,
I was brand new to North Carolina.
I'm from New York originally,
and it was, North Carolina
is in a remarkable place.
And now my family continues to live there
and I'm from North Carolina now.
After you go through leading
through a crisis like covid,
you bond with the state.
But it isn't, I loved
being there, but it was,
it was a different role
going to lead at the state,
at the state level than
the work I had done
at the federal government.
At the state level, you both get to build
much more authentic relationships.
You see the problems up close and personal
in a different way.
And North Carolina's a
challenging place to do work.
I worked for a Democratic governor.
We had a Republican super
majority in our legislature,
so a divided government.
We were very, have a very
stark divide, urban/rural
in North Carolina.
And so it was a really
interesting place to work.
But also I went there
to be Secretary of Health
and Human Services.
So I thought that was
an exciting challenge
because it wasn't just the
director of public health
or the head of Medicaid or
the head of mental health.
I got to think about knitting together
all of those health and human services
in service of health.
And we really kept that as our north star.
Really, how can we deliver health
for the people of North Carolina?
So as I think about public health,
I think that's what we're
trying to do, right?
Is think about populations
and how do we make them healthier.
And what that taught me
was you cannot do that
alone from public health.
I think if I had tried to just do that
from the perch of public health
without having the benefit
of thinking about the levers
of payment through Medicaid
or the service delivery and mental health,
or the social services that we had there.
We couldn't have put together
that comprehensive view
of trying to drive towards health.
So I felt pretty lucky
that before the pandemic,
I had three years of thinking about
how do we buy health.
I had a $20 billion a year budget,
which I will say is a
bigger than the CDC budget.
Yes, we get to, not kidding.
- Sadly. Yeah.
- We'll get to that.
So a pretty large budget
when you think about all of
those comprehensive services
and when you ask that question
of each and every one of those levers
from social services to mental health,
to public health to Medicaid,
to say how do we deliver and
buy health for this state?
It was pretty powerful.
And so I love being able to
bring together those levers.
So when I think about what did
I learn about public health,
it's a team sport.
And now being able to then take that,
what we were doing in terms
of building towards health
and then take that into
the crisis of the pandemic
was really important
because that means when
we went into the pandemic,
we were thinking about whole person health
in our response from day one.
And I was so lucky to work for,
I think the best governor
in the country, Roy Cooper.
He is just, I could not have asked
for a better boss and partner
in that response work.
And he called out right from the beginning
that trust was gonna be
the most important thing
that we could focus on
as we go into the crisis.
How do we build trust and
how do we maintain trust
with the people of North Carolina?
And that's really has shaped me
as I think about public health, right?
If we want the world to be different,
if we want the world to be healthier,
it always, for me comes back
time and time again to trust.
And trust, yes is a feeling,
but I'm sure we'll get into it,
but trust is a tactical plan
that you have to execute
on every single day.
And that's a lot of what I learned
about leading through
a public health crisis
at the state level.
And certainly a lot of what
I bring to the CDC work
as I'm three months in now.
- I love that the idea of
trust being a tactical plan.
You and I were just talking
about kind of the challenge
of so much of public
health is thinking about
who are the community partners?
How do we define the problems?
How do we describe accurately
the breadth, depth and hotspots?
But then you have to have a
plan for what to do afterwards.
And that's the other side of public health
that we so often don't talk about.
But that I think is one
of the special sauces
of certainly the YSM YSPH collaboration,
the collaboration of YSPH
with our school of management here.
And, and thanks to Howie as well,
the combination that collaboration
between the med school and
the school of management.
In terms of, I'm gonna
go on that trust theme.
We all cheered you on when you got
the directorship of the CDC.
It's just such an incredible honor
and I can't imagine anyone
better in this country
to lead the organization.
I know that recreating trust
has been a linchpin of what
you've been talking about.
You wrote a recent editorial
in "The New York Times"
trying to recreate trust in vaccines
and talking about how
you were getting yourself
as well as your children vaccinated.
I would love for you to share
a little bit about how
you think about that work
within the CDC, as well as some of your
other hopes and dreams for
your directorship at the CDC.
- Sure.
I feel like I got a masterclass
in thinking about trust,
like I said, working for Governor Cooper
and leading through the covid crisis.
And what I took away from that
around the tactical plan for trust
are really three buckets of work.
The first is transparency,
the second is simplicity in operations,
and I'll get to that, or great execution.
And the third is relationships.
So on the first is transparency.
I think the critical
linchpin of public health
is to bring visibility, data and evidence
to trying to solve how we protect health.
Whether it's identifying and responding
to a respiratory virus
or our first cases of
domestically acquired malaria,
which we had this year, first in 20 years.
Or it's understanding overdoses
from different types of
fentanyl or xylazine, right?
Having that data, that transparency
is critical to building trust.
So transparency for us was
absolutely fundamental.
And what's hard about transparency
is science is constantly
evolving as we know.
We are learning more things.
So it's really critical to be able to say,
this is what I know,
this is what I don't know,
and importantly, this is
what I'm working on to know.
And I'll come back to
you and you can trust
that this public health
is not a black box.
And I can't tell you still,
I was just with round table
of reporters yesterday
who said that public health
is a black box to us.
Help us understand it better.
We want to be your champions,
but we don't understand it, let us in.
All right, so transparency,
I think builds trust.
And in North Carolina, leading
through the covid crisis,
we did a press conference every day
at two o'clock for six months,
and then we did it every other
day for another six months.
And then we did it three times a week
or two times a week for that, right?
We did 170 press conferences.
I never thought I'd be that
person pointing to charts
and graphs on television every day.
But that transparency,
that that being there
willing to take questions
is really, really important.
And public health needs to both,
I think have simple and clear messages,
transparency in its data
as we're doing work.
Okay, that's one.
Then second, and this is, I
really feel strongly about.
In North Carolina, I
was not only the person
who was helping the public understand
the science and the data
for why we were making certain decisions,
I was also responsible for the execution
or the operations of the response.
Were there tests in my community?
Was there PPE for folks?
Was there vaccine when you
said it was going to be there?
The execution, because we can talk
and help people understand it,
but if they go and try to get a vaccine
and they've taken an hour off of work
and their appointment got canceled,
we've missed an opportunity
and we can study vaccines
and their effectiveness,
but if they sit on the
shelf, they're not effective.
And message is part of that communications
that's simple and trusted,
but it's also the operations
and the execution.
And for me, I'm an operator.
You heard I was chief
operating officer at CMS,
the largest payer in in the country.
And so I really feel like operations
and I want public health to make sure
that they feel accountable and ownership
over those operations
because we can't make folks
and help folks protect themselves
if we both don't get the operations right.
And then the third is relationships.
We're all humans at the end of the day.
And it is remarkable about how sometimes
we forget that and sitting down
with folks and building
relationships with takes time.
And I'll say the power of
showing up cannot be understated.
We spend a lot of time showing up
in communities that were
historically marginalized,
showing up and listening
was so important to trust building,
to relationship building.
I was lucky to have had three years
of relationship building across the aisle
before we went into the crisis.
And that was really important
so that we had a foundation,
but we had to nurture that
foundation through the crisis.
And it's why we had 99% of our seniors
got vaccinated in North Carolina.
North Carolina
- Extraordinary.
- Voted to elect Donald Trump twice.
Right, so it doesn't have to be partisan.
No, I think that there,
we tried to show a way where,
where we could come together.
We had all four of the two Democratic
and two of our top Republican leaders,
all four of them did
a vaccine video for us
saying get vaccinated
right, in North Carolina.
So we got to that place
because of relationships,
but also because of transparency
and good execution and
answering questions.
But that relationship piece is critical.
And that's, Roy Cooper
taught me that for sure.
- How lucky you are,
I will say having worked,
having spent 20 years
in Rhode Island where Gina Raimundo
was our most recent governor,
she's extraordinary.
It is amazing to watch these folks
that know how to get things done.
And I will say you are one of them
who I have enjoyed
watching get things done.
So you alluded in that
answer to two things
that I know are, have both been long time
focus of your career,
but also are key to your work at CDC.
One is around data and accuracy of data
and accurate capture of demographics
so that we can address
equity and pay attention
to the historically
marginalized communities
that are experiencing
disproportionate burden of disease.
The other is around community.
And I think back to your
work at Doctors for America
as an exemplar.
I would love to hear your reflections
on either or both of those.
- Sure.
- Thinking about both kind
of that data equity issue,
how you, I mean, really to me,
what you did in North Carolina
with getting demographic
data accurately measured
was just transformative.
How you're thinking about
that on a national level
and then how you take those
lessons from DFA forwards?
- Well, first I'm a data girl
and so I think that data is the oxygen
that powers our work,
particularly in public health.
If you can't see problems,
you can't solve problems.
We know that there are
disparities in our system,
but until you get that accurate data,
there's a lot of hand
waving of, ah, you know,
that's not my patient,
that's not my right.
So that clear, crisp data
that changes action is really necessary.
So let me talk about what
we did in North Carolina.
Well, we said equity was at the center
of what we were doing.
And so we, it was just unacceptable to us
to not be able to stratify
every piece of data
that we had by race and ethnicity.
We did it for gender and age too.
And so you couldn't log a
vaccine in North Carolina
without race and ethnicity.
And we had 99% completion on
our race and ethnicity data.
We won awards for that.
Very proud of that work.
And people fought us on it, said,
"Oh, patients don't wanna answer that."
or said, "It'll be too
slow for our systems."
We managed through it, right?
We came up with a bunch
of technology solutions,
but patients want to answer
that question or frankly,
why are they answering that question?
It's in the EHR already, guys,
let's pull it out, right?
So it was how do we think
about common sense solutions
to make that possible?
But then we have to use the data, right?
I think a lot of times,
frankly, in public health,
I love you all, but parsimony
is not always our strong suit in,
we just one more piece of
day, one more question,
one more piece of data.
We all have to collect race and ethnicity
in the same way every
time for every program.
So we have apples to apples comparison
against across every program.
It seems super basic,
but we don't do it at the CDC right now.
Guess who will?
- You're also kind of not
allowed to do it, right?
There's some data use
agreement issues right?
- I don't think we can get past that.
So I don't like to tolerate that, right?
And so I'm always a how
do we find a way, right?
But, so this is where I
also think we have to one,
expect that, but then we have
to use that data for action, right?
And so it wasn't just
the collecting of it,
then we're just admiring
the problem, right?
It's the changing action.
And what was powerful about it
is that when we were
responding to the crisis
on a day-to-day basis,
we were looking at that
information and we said,
"Why aren't vaccines over there?
"Why is that community at a lower rate?
"That hit that Latino community
over there at a lower rate?
"Let's deploy resources over there."
Or you pick up the phone
and say, did you know,
did you know this is happening, right?
And so you have to make that actionable
and it's a self reinforcing. Yeah.
So when you are actually using it
and people are like,
oh, this is so useful,
now I wanna collect the data.
No questions asked.
So it's great.
Last thing I'll say on data
though that we're doing
is in addition to standardization
on how we collect, so it's most useful.
We have to, all of us,
no matter where we sit,
whether it's CDC or academia
or the health systems,
we have to get away from the mindset
of this data is mine.
There's a lot of, well
I've done the hard work
of collecting this data
and cleaning it out.
- I get to publish from it, yeah.
- I'm gonna publish my data
and I appreciate that.
But particularly I'm
working on with it CDC
and with our state partners,
we have to move away from
the data is mine mindset.
Data is a national security asset, right?
Is how we are going to protect this nation
as we go forward.
And we have to find ways
to be able to share that
data across the board.
We did it for covid.
If we can do it for covid,
we should do it across the board.
We have to do it for
covid and flu and RSV.
Let's start there.
So right now we have great
data sharing and visibility.
So if you wanna know
what's happening with covid
in your backyard, you can know it,
but you don't know about flu,
you don't know about RSV
in the same way.
We're working to change that.
And I'm working with our
state partners, right?
Because to your point,
there are different authorities and such.
But we have to move
ourselves towards that path.
And I'm looking for a
coalition of the willing
to go on down that path with me
and then I'll work with Congress
to show why with that power
why that's so necessary.
And that's needing help from
our health systems as well.
So the data is mine mindset has to go,
we need that data to
power healthy communities.
And so we need to move
quickly in that direction.
- Love that.
So I'm gonna do one more question,
then I'm gonna open it up. Dr. Juthani,
I'm sure is both ready to be
a coalition of the willing,
but also we're excited for
her to moderate questions.
So my last question is a
slightly more personal one,
knowing that this is a room of staff,
faculty and students who came here
to be inspired and to learn a
little bit about your journey.
It's kind of a question about
if you had the chance to go back in time
and you have the opportunity now to speak
to a bunch of aspiring leaders themselves.
What do you wish you had learned?
What are you thankful you learned?
What do you encourage
the folks in the room
to pursue as future public health leaders?
- So two pieces of advice
that I've been giving for a while now.
Some one which I think I followed
and one which I was disappointed I didn't.
So I'll do the good first,
is be uncomfortable.
I had this opportunity, my career has,
so like now I can go back and tell
like this nice story about
- You're here.
- how it made sense.
But my career like zigzagged a bit
in terms of was this
the right step for me?
And what I realize now in hindsight
is that building differentiated
kinds of skill sets
allowed me to open doors
to different kinds of opportunities.
So if I had just taken jobs
that were fit for a doctor,
I don't think I would have been able
to make the progress in my career.
There were times where I
was the communications lead,
there was times where I was the data lead.
There were times when
it was my clinical
expertise that mattered.
It was sometimes it was
my policy expertise.
Sometimes I was just needing
to be a good manager.
And so building different
kinds of skill sets,
but that does require you to
step out of your comfort zone.
Sometimes crisis pulls
you in that direction.
And I would say sometimes
crisis is an opportunity.
So think about moments of big change.
For me, like I said, when
healthcare.gov didn't turn on,
that was a big crisis
moment for the organization
I was with.
I got to step out
dramatically from where I was.
I was doing physician payment models.
Pretty typical what, you know,
what folks would be thinking of
where I went to work to
run the call center, right?
So that was a hard conversation
to have with my mom
when she was like, what are you
doing running a call center?
But, and I was uncomfortable.
I was like, I don't know
anything about a call center.
But you know what,
it was a fantastic learning experience
to dive into something I didn't know.
Think about leadership
and management, right?
And that allowed me to start
opening my mind a bit about skill building
in different ways.
So be uncomfortable.
Second, the other part is
about asking great questions
in whatever environment you're in.
And I feel like this is where I fell down.
Looking back now,
I think there were moments
where I didn't take
advantage of opportunities
to ask questions of people I was around.
'Cause I wanted everyone
to think I already knew the answers.
Everyone wants to.
- I can't imagine anyone
in this room feels that way, right?
- You wanna front and be like, I got this.
And I missed opportunities
to really understand
things earlier in my career
when I should have understood 'em earlier
if I just asked good
questions at the time.
And I am so, I am always so enamored
by young students who ask
really good questions.
I'm like, I wish I could have asked
those kind of questions
when I was your age.
I would've been much smarter
sitting in the seat right now.
Sometimes I had to do all the wrong things
and learn the lesson.
So ask the questions.
Trust me if you have a question,
others have a question.
But it's also the
opportunity to learn, right?
No one expects you early in your career
to know all the things.
So please, like, ask good questions.
Don't feel like you have
to know all the answers.
And I would say that in any job.
I would say the more I do in leadership,
the way I lead is not,
sometimes you need to
be a directive leader.
But most of the time I'm going to the team
to be like, what should we do?
What should we do here?
I will help you do it.
And my job as the leader is to
break down barriers for you.
If this is the right
thing to do, I'm gonna.
If there's an authority problem,
I'm gonna fix it, right?
If there's politics we need to
get through, how can I help?
If we need to communicate,
what can I do, right?
But I'm gonna go to the folks to say,
what should I, what should I do?
And it is to this day, the fact
that I've been able to hone my ability
to ask good questions,
I think that has helped
me further my career.
- I love that.
And what a beautiful segue
into a chance for questions to be asked.
So thank you.
Thank you for sharing those, Mandy.
I think that's lovely.
And I do really want
to kind of double click
on the idea that careers
are not straight lines.
And so for those who are
sitting out in the audience
wondering what their next step is
to not hesitate to take that risk
and to not feel like
you have to have it all figured out now.
I feel like particularly for
kind of our newer generation,
there's this sense that you need to know
on the day when you start
your graduate program,
what you're going to do next.
And I don't, maybe you knew
you were gonna do internal
medicine or public health,
but I sure surprised myself.
Thank you, Dr. Juthani.
- Thank you both.
We wanna have an opportunity for people
to be able to ask questions.
There are microphone rovers in the room,
so if anybody has a question,
feel free to raise your hand at this time.
We have a few in the front here.
- [Audience Member] Hi
Dean Ranney and Dr. Cohen,
thank you so much for being here.
I wanted to get your thoughts
on online misinformation
and disinformation
as a public health threat.
- Little teeny topic.
- Yeah, very small.
Yeah, so I know as early
as recent as last year,
DHS tried to launch a
disinformation governance board
and that ultimately failed.
And we know a lot of disinformation
is rooted in fear and misinformation.
So how, what is the appropriate strategy
to neutralize it, right?
If there aren't any financial incentives
or if the political
incentives aren't even there.
So what can everyone do to combat that?
- Yes, I think this is
really important topic.
So a couple ways that I
thought about this, right?
So I think those of us
with the good information
need to drown out the
bad information, right?
It's a flood the zone approach.
So that so much good
information is out there
that the misinformation is muted.
But understand that in order for us
to get good information out,
we have to understand how folks
are consuming that information
and they're consuming it as entertainment.
And we are not entertaining.
I wish I was.
- Right, but to us, you are.
- So let's just be honest
and I think we have to
meet folks where they are
and think about different
ways to communicate
the good information.
So one, we have to just
do more of it, right?
If everyone here sees some misinformation
and then tweets the right information
or sorry, X now.
- Threads, get on threads, folks.
Yeah, exactly.
- So, right, right.
And we need to, we can't,
you are complicit if we
just like let that stand.
So we need to flood the zone
with the good information,
but we also have to flood it
with information that
feels engaging to folks.
And I'm, to be honest,
like I think we're all
still figuring this out
and how to do this well.
And like I think the
government particularly
has a lot of challenges doing that
for a lot of not good reasons,
but some good reasons.
And so we need to figure
out how to engage better.
Far too often, and I was
saying this this morning
to the team at the Fairhaven clinic,
the team at CDC, I love them.
They're so smart and
they're like, I'm so proud.
I put some fantastic information
up on our website site.
Like, oh boy, I haven't gone
to a website for information,
I don't know when right?
And I can't, I love public health
and I go to the right.
So that's not gonna be good.
That's not good enough.
We have to modernize
the way we communicate
as a strategy related to disinformation.
Then there's a whole
regulatory architecture
that we need to think about.
I am a hundred percent fully
supportive of free speech,
but I think there's nothing
about free amplification
that we need to think about.
And so there's something
there in the middle
where we can, everyone can
say the things they wanna say,
but they don't all need
to be amplified in a way.
And there's again, but
that's in the world of laws
and regulations that folks
need to really think about
that's broader than even just
public health information.
It's bigger than that.
So what we can do in
healthcare and public health
is to flood the zone
with good information.
We can be engaging, we can be trusted.
And yes, people get their
information from social media,
but the most trusted folks
at survey after survey after survey,
your doctor and your nurse, right?
The nurse at your church and
your own personal doctor.
So like every time you're
walking into a room with someone,
you have an opportunity
to influence their lives.
The number one reason
people don't get vaccinated,
their doctor didn't
mention it at the visit,
didn't say it was important.
Not 'cause they thought it was,
the doctor didn't mention it.
They would've mentioned
it if it was important,
but mention it, right?
So every, we have to
take every opportunity.
We don't have, I don't think we're ever
gonna be quite as engaging online.
So like let's take every
opportunity in person
that we possibly can.
- We have a question in
the front row over here.
And then we'll go to the one in the back.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you for the opportunity.
And my question is for both of you.
Part of the answer may be
that both of you are here.
So we are aware that always assume
that all of us know the importance
of the relation between
institutes such as CDC
with academic research
institutes like Yale.
So if you can elaborate
more on this collaboration
and relationship, like
to inform the decisions
and the policies and also like
what would you do different
to strengthen such
collaboration and relationship?
Thank you.
- Well obviously our academic partners
are incredibly important
to train the future,
the current and future
leaders of public health.
So very important as we're thinking about
what are those skillset
that folks need to build.
But there's also really
important questions
that get answered in academia.
And we saw, frankly during the pandemic
case number one of like
our academic partners
being trusted voices to
share really good information
and so, so critical.
But it's also about
prioritization together
and having a shared agenda
on what are we trying to accomplish.
I think there's more
work we need to do there
between public health and academia.
What are the things that CDC
needs to research and do?
What are the things that academia,
that CDC can't do that academia could do
in different ways?
I don't think we have as much
of a unified shared agenda
as we need to.
I think that's on the to-do list.
I'm only a few, you know?
- Yeah, we're both a couple of months in.
Yeah, getting to, we're
getting to it, right?
- But we need to do that
because I think there
are certain things CDC
needs to stop doing.
I think there are certain things
that academia needs to pick
up to do, but what, right?
And we have to have that collaboration
back and forth to be like,
okay, if you've got this,
then we're gonna nod
and we'll go over there.
'Cause there's so many important
things we all need to do.
There's too much work in the world, right?
So I think there's more
work we need to do.
But Dean, getting over to you.
- Exactly what you just said.
I think that we think of ourselves at,
we can think of ourselves as extenders
of each other's skillsets.
We do sit in slightly different places
within the ecosystem of
public health and healthcare.
And so how do we work in partnership
to do the things that maybe CDC
or our state and local health departments
wish they could do, but can't.
They don't have the staff,
they don't have the infrastructure.
Maybe they don't have the
very specialized expertise.
And then vice versa, our
partnership back, CDC
and state and local health departments
have an unbelievable platform
to disseminate, to implement,
to actually change policies and procedures
on the ground and have
an incredible workforce
that is present in almost every community
across the United States.
And then if we look globally,
certainly there are
partnerships there as well.
And so knowing kind of
how then on our side,
the information gets shared
and made actionable is huge.
The the last part that I'll say
that I see is an existing
source of partnership
that we can grow is around grants,
around support of not just research,
but also implementation.
For those who aren't aware,
CDC is a tremendous funder
of not just research,
but also on the ground
implementation work.
And I think that it
behooves us as academics
to think about how we
can be better partners
in that space as well.
But the shared agenda is something
that I'm excited to
work on going forwards.
And I think we're gonna have
a bunch of opportunities
to think a little differently
as we move into this new
ecosystem of public health
and healthcare about how we can amplify
and extend each other's work.
- I have a question in
the back, I believe.
Yeah, go ahead.
- [Nora] Sure.
Dr. Cohen, so nice to have you here.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Nora Alsabi.
I'm a first year at the Yale
School of Public Health.
So my question actually has two parts.
First, I'm just wondering,
what are some of the strategies
adapted from covid that
are kind of being used
to be implemented in the future
or the preparedness phase
for like any future pandemic?
Second part is actually one
that I'm very interested in.
I'm just wondering if there
has been any initiatives
or your review on preparing programming
or any other kind of part of initiatives
to address immigrant health
issues in the United States,
and what would that look
like in the upcoming years?
- Great, so on the first,
in terms of lessons learned from covid,
there are so many, so many, so many.
But I'll go back to some core ones,
which is we need data infrastructure
to see issues and solve problems.
I think we, my first effort
as North Carolina secretary
was an effort we called Kill the Fax.
And that's because we were getting
lab data by fax, ugh, ugh,
when we went into a historic pandemic.
So I had 250 people entering
information into a computer
until we killed the fax,
but right, so we've built
systems now, fantastic.
But we built them for covid.
But there's some railroad
tracks there, right?
So we've laid some tracks
on how to build pipes
and think about this.
And so CDC is being funded
for a huge data monetization effort
that's across CDC, it's to the states,
a lot of work being done.
We have to get systems
that talk to each other
across healthcare and public health.
So a lot, I mean, absolutely
fundamentally have to do that.
If we want to call this
a public health system,
data integration is like
absolutely fundamental.
Then there is all of the work related
to how we recognize public
health as a team sport.
We saw how we needed to
bring in different folks
and clarifying roles and responsibilities
in peace time versus crisis time.
What are the right roles
and responsibilities
for the health delivery system?
I'll say in North Carolina,
our major hospital systems
were hugely important.
And I again, give huge credit to them,
I would convene these competitors, right?
They're business competitors
across our state.
I'd convene them every Monday morning
to make sure that we were
aligned and executing.
But that's not the norm, right?
That's in crisis.
So how do we think about
roles and responsibility
not in crisis as well?
And then the communication
and trust building.
You can't build trust in a crisis.
You have to be there throughout.
So the trust building has to start now
for a crisis we may have
10 years from now, right?
In the communities that we need to be in.
So I heard an interesting
point this morning at Fairhaven
that, you know, we're
spending a lot of effort
on the mental health crisis and they said,
you know what, more than
the mental health crisis,
we're actually seeing dental health
as one of the most significant
needs for the community here.
And I was like, oh, well
one, oh, that's so hard
and, but so important.
So let's start, let's
listen as leaders, right?
That's how you build trust.
You listen to what are the
community's first top priorities.
Let's solve that.
So that in five years,
if we have another crisis,
hopefully not right?
That we are there,
we're solving problems that
matter to the community.
So like we have to, like now is when
we have to do the preparation
and in terms of our immigrant communities,
what I love about public health
and I'm so proud of CDC
and only being there three months,
I take no credit for this,
but it is honestly the most
equity focused organization
that I have been part of.
And I'm very proud of
the North Carolina work.
But it was a lot of like new work.
When I come to CDC and I see it,
the equity work is embedded
everywhere in a great way.
And they think about populations
and they are thinking about migrant
and their health at all times
and thinking about how do we make sure
we're understanding what they need
and think about it.
So for example, I was just on the phone
with folks in New York who are seeing
a lot of new immigrants
and migrants that are there
and how can we help them
from an infectious disease place,
but also from housing
and things like that.
So CDC, like that's,
I give them a ton of credit
for doing incredible work.
The resources are what is missing there.
It's not the passion,
it's not the strategy,
it's resources in order to make sure
that we can help all those communities.
- And if I can just jump
in real, two things.
One is around the migrants.
It is just to put a finer point on that,
partnerships, I recently
had a lovely conversation
with the head of health and
human services in Massachusetts.
They're also struggling
with the same problem.
And it really is the partnerships
that it's not all on
DHHS helping to provide
a livelihood and a life to allow folks
to start to integrate.
So often, we think about health
as sitting off in this bubble
versus being part of this
much larger ecosystem
of issues and things that
help to create health.
The other thing is you were talking about
the data modernization initiative.
Going back to your question,
something that we can do in academia
is to help tell the
story of why CDC matters
and of why their initiatives matter.
So I bring up the data
modernization initiative
anytime I talk to a policymaker.
CDC has asked for 165
million, more or less,
more than that.
You're going up, you're going up
from Michelle's estimate, okay?
That's less than it costs
to put Epic into one
hospital system. Yeah.
- That's why my number's bigger.
- Good.
But just to kind of put that in context,
people don't think about it.
If you're talking to policymakers,
they don't think about data
as court of public health
the way that we do.
And so we have that
chance to tell the story.
We also have the chance to tell the story
of why CDC matters,
why this work matters in
those community relationships
and to help create the connections
that then allow you to
hear that dental health
is the primary concern of the community
that's being treated at this
major FQHC in New Haven.
So just as an addition
to the beautiful question
that you asked earlier,
and Nora, thank you.
- Dr. Cohen, we are killing
the fax in Connecticut.
We haven't quite killed it,
but your data modernization
efforts are helping us get there.
Okay, we have, I know several
other questions I saw.
Okay, right here on the front.
- [Audience Member]
Great, thank you so much.
Thank you for being here.
I had a question on
behalf of a person I know
who's on dialysis and they were wondering
why it's not required
for healthcare workers
to wear N95 respirators
in healthcare settings.
Especially when decades of research
showed that respirators are more effective
than surgical mass at
preventing airborne diseases.
And with like 60% of covid infections,
asymptomatic and hospital
acquired infections
four times higher,
have a four times higher
risk of mortality.
- So great question.
So we have different teams who
are looking at some of
these issues right now,
and I think updating some
of the guidance, right?
So I think you wanna look at,
we look at a couple of factors
when thinking about it.
Sure, is an N95 gonna certainly filter out
more things than a surgical mask?
Yes, we know how those work, right?
If you have something that's fit tested
and the different material.
So, but the question
is what are the things
that you need to wear an N95 for?
And what are the things
where surgical barrier masks make sense?
And you wanna look both at the way
the infection is spread, but
also what is the risk, right?
So we spread a lot of
things that are aerosolized,
but there there are
different levels of risk.
It is good news in 2023 where
we are related to covid.
97% of us have either had it
or have been vaccinated by it.
So we aren't in the same
place we were in 2020
when we had an entire population
that's never been exposed.
Now I wouldn't, I have to be
on brand for CDC director.
I'm glad we got to this.
Our immunity is going down,
the virus is changing.
Please all get your updated covid vaccine.
Even those of us who are,
I almost was saying I'm
as young as you, I'm not,
I'm getting my vaccine.
But please, everyone at every age
should get it as well as your flu shot.
But my point is, is that we have to think
about levels of risk for all of those
different kinds of diseases versus
in terms of what is the
protection level that we need.
And so, those are the kinds of research
that the team goes through.
We actually have an
independent advisory committee
that is going through some
of that work right now
to understand the data
and what, how do you map
to the right protection because it's both
how is it transmitted,
but also like what is the
risk to all of the patients?
And we sort of need to
balance all of those things.
- Great, thank you.
I know there are a few others.
Right behind the last person who asked.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you for being here.
This question is addressed to both of you,
but it's based on something
that Dr. Cohen said.
You said earlier that data is
a national securities asset
and we need to move away
from a data is mine mindset.
And so I was wondering whether
you think there's a place
for the CDC or just
general US health policy
to maybe require this data sharing,
especially in the realm of public health
because it's so important
to just our general health
in general for the whole country?
- The short answer is yes.
So I am, and I talk about
it with members of congress
whenever I have a conversation with them.
Now I understand why we
have to have a balance here.
Just like balance in the last
question I was talking about,
we wanna collect data
to have that visibility.
We need to protect privacy.
Absolutely, I think that is important too.
A lot of the data and
that can be actionable,
can be de-identified in
the way that we collect it
and use it and it still be actionable.
There are some places where
that shouldn't be true
in terms of case identification,
but those are the things
we're trying to work through
with Congress and help them understand,
de-identify data is what
we're really talking about
as the asset that we need to understand
and respond to threats.
And I think we're making
some progress there.
But you know, unfortunately
these modernized data systems
and all, they're expensive.
Also, just candidly, data is a,
gives you market power
in the healthcare system.
And so, there are different
forces that pull upon this.
So we're gonna try to tell the story
of why we need this data.
I am spent most of my career
on the health delivery side.
We have to do this in a way
that is not burdensome to
the health delivery system.
We need to pull and extract
the data out of EHRs.
We cannot ask for additional
manual work for folks.
So this is where my,
I'm wearing my CMS hat
for a second, right?
CMS has a lot of mechanisms
in which we collect data already.
Public health needs to
fit into that mechanism.
So we need to make sure
it's not burdensome.
We need to make sure that
the privacy is protected.
But yes, additional authorities
are absolutely needed
to keep the country safe.
- And that gets to your
simplicity precept around trust,
which is that we have
to make it really easy
for people to gather, share, and use data.
I will say that there is actually
any of you who have CDC,
NIH or NSF funded grants
know that we are already
expected to share data,
to deposit whatever data we can
in a shared data repository,
whether it's quantitative or qualitative.
Once you have removed
those markers of privacy,
I also think, to your point around that,
that privacy and ethical question,
it's why it's so important for us
to think about this being done
not on an individual basis,
but on an individual locality basis,
but across states,
regions, and the country.
Because what we often find
is that some of our smallest groups,
their data gets suppressed over and over.
So it limits our ability
to look with granularity
to Mandy's earlier point about data equity
at, for example, native Hawaiian
and Pacific Islander populations.
Because in a given locale,
the numbers may be so small
that then it becomes identifiable.
So it's a way to think about
kind of improving equity
as well as data sharing.
But this goes back to your
work in North Carolina.
You were so committed to creating spaces
where that even if
perhaps the full dataset
couldn't be shared, that the summaries
of the data could be,
which allows access in in other ways.
And then I think helped
you to be a convener
of data sources
- Yes, and I was gonna say, I love,
we have amazing scientists at the CDC
and they are incredible.
They want precision and sometimes
that's not gonna be possible
in the messy world that we live in.
And so thinking about, well,
if we can't collect everything,
what's half a loaf?
I'll take that to start.
So we're trying to get to that place.
- Okay. We've got about six minutes left,
so I'm gonna try to take two,
but let's take one question.
There was one in the back there
and then we'll try to come
back here to the front
if we can fit it in.
In the back.
- [Lena] Hello. Oh, hello.
Thank you for being here, Dr. Cohen.
I can only imagine your busy schedule
and taking the time to be here for us
is very gratitude
instilling, but thank you.
My name is Lena Jones, I'm a
third year in Yale undergrad.
And I wanted to ask about how,
as a woman of data you
plan for data's ethical use
because I know that
there's this long history
of data being collected and
intended for wonderful purposes,
and then it's actual application
ends up harming the communities
that it was most intended to serve.
- Yeah, great question.
This is part of the,
you need to protect
privacy as we go, right?
So a lot of times we can do this,
do the data collection
without making sure that we're
identifying any individual.
That's the first.
But I think this goes to deep
seated decades upon decades
where the structural way
in which we both collect
and use data there, as we know,
there is racism built into our structures.
And so then when we take,
even the way we collect data,
having disparities built into it,
and then we try to use
these new tools like AI
or our large language models,
like we perpetuate those disparities.
So we have to really be
thinking about it proactively
on the front end.
But honestly, when I hear your question,
it always goes back to trust, right?
Are we having the
conversation on the front end
and helping the community see
is like when we ask these questions
and we're collecting this data,
it's to help come back to you
to make sure that it's better
and actually deliver on that.
It's why knowing that dental
is the most important issue
here is really powerful.
So we could be off collecting
data on covid vaccines,
but everyone's like, well, really?
Why aren't you collecting data
on what's going on
related to my oral health?
And so I think it's also having
those trusting conversations
with folks and then also making sure
that you're always being value add
and we have to check
ourselves in public health.
'Cause I think we come in with
a lot of idealistic thoughts
about what a community needs
and that we really need to make sure
we're taking a beat to listen.
- And here I'll just
say if this is an issue
that interests you, check out Datahaven,
which is a local organization
run by one of our YSPH
graduates, Mark Abraham,
that does a lovely job
collecting, sharing and empowering
communities to use local
data around health.
So a lovely example.
- Great.
- Yeah, it's super cool.
It's super cool.
- Okay, we have time for
one quick last question
right here in the front, please.
Last question.
- [Rachel] Hi, okay, I will make it quick.
Hi, I'm Rachel.
I'm a second year at the
Yale School of Public Health.
I actually work for the
commissioner over the summer,
so it's great to see you all in person.
My question is, what do you
see as the role of the CDC
in advancing whole Person
health on a national scale?
And how will that dovetail
the localized state
efforts already in motion?
- Big question to end and I'll
go back to where I started.
I actually think public
health is one piece of that,
and it has to be a team sport.
I think there's a lot of
pieces in public health,
but I'll go back to like public health
is not resourced to fulfill
its current mission,
which is identifying and
responding to threats.
And so it, we do, but there is a lot
of public health
principles that I wanna map
to all of the levers across healthcare.
And that's not just
health delivery system.
As I said, social services
has to be part of it.
Education has to be part of it.
Transportation has to be part of it.
So this is a US government approach
and frankly, gotta get the
private sector, academia, right?
It's a team sport here.
And that's, for me, like
that's the exciting part
is how do we knit these pieces together?
What I'm trying to do at CDC
is make us the best collaborator
we absolutely possibly could be.
Now, I think data is
the power behind that.
Because like that visualization,
but it's building a muscle of
collaboration is different.
How like, candidly, like CDC
does not have right now
someone who owns engagement,
stakeholder engagement or they,
we wanna call it
something else, but right,
but doesn't have that function.
But if we're gonna be
the best collaborator,
and if this is a team sport,
we absolutely have to build
that muscle differently.
So those are the kinds of
things I'm working on at CDC,
but we have a lot to offer
in and of itself, right?
With the data evidence and best practices
so that we can go to someone like CMS
and be like, you know what
you should be paying for
is X, not Y, right?
Or we can go to SAMHSA
and say, you know what?
We, we've studied this best
practice in suicide prevention.
This is where you should put your money.
And they do.
And we're doing that right now
so that we're trying to model out
those best opportunities
for collaboration,
make sure public health is strong
in what it can offer in
terms of data evidence
best practices, and then that can,
but don't leave it there.
That's to get to the folks
who then deliver the services
so that they know how to use
the data evidence best practices.
And so like making those connection points
is like very important to me.
And so we're gonna be doing
a lot of that at the CDC,
but we can't do it alone.
And it'll be a team sport
and everyone's on team health.
So thank you.
- Well, I cannot think of anyone better
to exemplify leadership in
public health than Dr. Cohen.
I cannot thank you enough
on behalf of all of us.
We do have a small, so
a thank you to Mandy.
Thank you.
So I wanna thank Claire,
who, if those don't know her,
is the brains and heart
who works with Howie
and allows him to have
brains and heart as well.
Not that he didn't have them before.
but thank you Claire for your help.
And we have a small gift bag for you.
As well as for Dr. Juthani,
as a thank you to both of you
also exemplifying
leadership and public health
on behalf of our state.
Again, just a very warm thank you
to both of them for their
presence, leadership, and grace.
- Thank you all for coming.
And for this inspirational
conversation today.